- All right, everybody.
We are back with an audience full
of female sports ball fans,
(audience applauding)
to celebrate the new movie
80 for Brady.
We're also joined by
the stars of the film,
total icons and legends,
Jane Fonda, Lily Tomlin,
Sally Field and Rita Moreno.
(audience applauding and cheering)
So did any of you actually
play sports growing up?
- [Lily] Ola.
- You played sports, right?
- Yeah.
- Sally did too.
- No, I was a cheerleader,
does that count?
- I was a cheerleader too.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
- I'm sorry, but where I'm from,
cheerleaders are more
athletic than most people.
So that's a sport where I'm from.
- Yeah, well, I didn't
know of any sports, I mean.
- [Kelly] Look how cute you are.
(audience cheering)
- No, no, I mean, I
didn't know of any sports
that women played when I went to school.
Oh, good God in heaven, how did I-
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] I was like, she doesn't see it.
- [Lily] Well I wish you
had a cute picture of me.
- No, I didn't know any
women went out for sports.
That was it.
That was the sport I knew of.
- Was this before you
were Gidget or anything?
- Yes, that was before.
Yeah, I was in high school.
I wasn't Gidget yet.
But she lived inside me.
(audience applauding)
(all laughing)
- So you played, was it softball?
- I did, I played softball.
I pitched, I was the pitcher.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] That's like a boss position.
- I know, well, I couldn't
see a better place for me
on the team
- Just to be the star?
- Yeah, that's right.
- I love it so much.
Okay, well, speaking of being athletic,
how many of you used to do
the Jane Fonda workout videos?
(audience cheering and applauding)
- I did it with Jane Fonda.
- [Jane] So did Sally.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I did it with my mom.
- I actually, I actually used to,
her first workout place-
- Yeah.
- Was in the valley.
And I used to go, because
I lived in the valley.
And one day there she
was teaching the class.
It was like jaw dropping.
And I was like working
out right behind her.
I luckily was in the business then,
but just a very tiny
aspect of the business.
'Cause I was doing television
and she was already-
- I attended her class too.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Do you remember that?
Do you remember me?
- No.
- [Rita] You don't?
(audience laughing)
- I remember Sally.
I don't remember you.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh.
- That is (indistinct).
That is real friendship.
(audience cheering)
- Don't go, don't go.
No, no, don't go.
Come back, come back.
She'll make it up to you.
(Rita sobbing)
- I remember you Rita.
- I remember you.
- We all remember you.
Rita, we remember you.
- You are memorable.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Just not to her
- Jane, Jane.
- [Jane] Huh?
- It's too (beep) late.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering and applauding)
- I would assume it's obviously
the comedian of the group,
that is probably the funniest,
but I feel like you could
probably all hold your own
with wit, right?
Am I right?
Who's like the funniest woman
when you're going out or you're talking?
- She's the one that made
me laugh the loudest.
- Okay.
- Sally is a very, very funny-
- [Kelly] She's like bewildered a bit.
- But you know what?
(audience laughing)
They're all funny.
- I think I didn't even mean
to be funny, I think I said good morning,
and she burst out laughing.
(all laughing)
- Lily, makes me laugh.
- Oh, obviously, that was kind of
my first guess.
(audience cheering)
How about the flirtiest?
Who's the flirtiest?
- Rita, yeah.
- I was going to say
maybe either one of you.
I was going to say, one of you two-
- No, I mean, honestly, Rita
knows I'm going, oh my God.
Get the bag for this woman.
Like jeez,
(audience laughing)
somebody give her the hawk,
for goodness sakes.
- No, live your life.
- Can I tell you a story about that.
- Yeah, one hundred percent, please.
- Good, one day.
- [Sally] Oh no.
- When Jane and I-
- Oh no.
(all laughing)
- I can't wait.
- I love you, but shut up.
(audience laughing)
So one day Jane and I
are sitting in the dark
waiting for a scene to get lit.
And it's just the two of us.
And Jane, out of the blue, says to me,
"How do you feel about sex?"
(audience chuckling)
And I immediately said, oh God
no, I'm done, ew. (groaning)
(audience laughing)
And she said, okay.
So about a week later we
were all going to do a scene
in the locker room.
And in the locker room are
these amazing, amazing people.
(audience laughing)
The guys.
The guys in the movie.
And we all
are starting to make-
- Even Jane's doing it now.
- We're entering the room.
This is not part of the scene.
This is just, we're entering the room.
And to my absolute,
this is true,
absolute, I have to stand up.
(audience cheering)
- She needs the floor. (laughing)
(audience cheering and applauding)
- She takes to her stage.
- To my absolute amazement,
I swear to God,
swear to God, to my absolute amazement.
I take a deep breath and I go...
(Rita inhaling deeply)
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
And then I said to myself,
pheromones.
(audience laughing)
- What did she say?
- [Kelly] Pheromones.
- [Rita] Do exist.
- I'm talking to myself and saying,
oh my God, what's the matter with you?
You're 90 for God's sake, you're 90.
- You're alive.
- And you know, I know now,
that somewhere in here.
- Does anyone know the words
to Moon River?
(Lily laughing)
- There was a little ovary saying,
"everybody up."
(hands clapping)
(audience cheering and applauding)
- [Jane] That's a good story.
- [Rita] It's a great story.
- Oh my God.
- And it's true.
There must have been.
Because what suddenly attacked me?
♪ Moon River wider than a mile ♪
(all laughing)
♪ I'm crossing you in style some day ♪
- Oh my God, I wish you all
could stay here forever.
Okay, wait, I can only imagine
what this set was like.
It's amazing it was finished,
the film, it's amazing.
(audience laughing)